بعد معارك طويله زعيم وفاقنار يرفع علم
روسيا على مبنى اداره الاوكراني
ومع اقتراب موعد نزولها امام المحكمه
ترامب يدعو انصاره الى التبرع لحملته
الانتخابيه
انفجار سياره مفخخه في دمشق الجيش
الاسرائيلي يعترض مسيره من جهه الاراضي
السوريه
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره لاهم الانباء من العربيه البدايه
بالملف الاوكراني حيث اعلن قائد مجموعه
باجنر العسكريه الروسيه
رفع العلم روسيا على مبنى اداره مدينه
بخموت شرقي اوكرانيا واضاف بيرغاجين ان
القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت في الاجزاء
الغربيه للمدينه
اختاروا يا بريله اليوم الثاني من ابريل
بالتحديد الساعه الحاديه عشره مساء خلفي
مبنى اداره مدينه بخموت هذا هو العلم
الروسي كتب عليه
تحديدا لذكراه الطيبه لقد اخذنا مخموت من
وجهه نظر قانونيه قاده وحدات القوات
الروسيه الذين تولوا اداره المدينه والحي
المركزيه باكمله سيرفعون الاعلام العدو ظل
في الاحياء الغربيه
رئاسه الاوكرانيه في موضوع اخر نفت الضلوع
في تفجير احد المقاهي في سنه
وقالت لسلطات الروسيه كانت السلطات روسيه
قد اعلنت في وقت سابقا ان تفجير استهدف
المناصره الحربيه التابعه لماجنار فلادلين
تتراسكي واشارت الى ان تفجير تم عبر زرع
عبوه الناسفه في تمثال سلمه احد الحاضرين
حيث اقيمت حفله للمراسل الحربي في المقهى
ويعتبر تاتاراسكي احد ابرز المدونين عن
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
ومدون معروف فقد حياته في تفجير احد
المقاهي في مدينه سامبرسبرغ الروسيه حسب
وزاره الداخليه لم تتبنى حتى الان اي جهه
مسؤوليه الانفجار كما لم تقدم السلطات اي
تفاصيل عما قالت ان سببه هو قنبله كانت
بحوزه احد رواد المقهى لكن مقاطع ما قبل
لحظات من التفجير اظهرت تتارسكي وهو يحمل
تمثالا صغيرا قدم له من احد رواد المقهى
يبدو بانها هي تلك القنبله التي تسببت
بالحادثه بحسب وسائل اعلام روسيه
مصدر في قوات الامن لوكاله تاسك قال بان
قوه العبوه الناسفه تجاوزت 200 جرام من
ماده تي ان تي وبحسب منظم الحدث داخل
المقهى فان الاجراءات الامنيه الضعيفه
سمحت بوقوع التفجير لكن السر يكمن في
خفايا المقهى المتضرر من التفجير فهو مقهى
تعود ملكيته لقائد مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه
الروسيه حسب اعلام روسي
والابرز شخصيه الصحفي المستهدف فمقاطع
فيديو سابقه للمراسل الحربي المقتول يظهر
فيها وهو يردد عبارات تحريضيه
تشير الى انه مؤيد للعمليه العسكريه
الروسيه الا انه ينتقد استراتيجيه
الجنرالات في وزاره الدفاع كما يفعل قائده
مؤسس فاجنر
سنهزم الجميع وسنقتل الجميع وسنسلب كل من
يحتاج الى السرقه وسيكون كل شيء كما نحب
مقهى يعد ثاني اهم حادثه بعد سابقه لها
العام الماضي اودت بحياه داريا دوجينا
ابنه الكسندر دوجن الفيلسوف الروسي المقرب
من الرئيس بوتين في انفجار سياره يشتبه
بانها كانت ملغمه روان حمزه العربيه
قالت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زخرفه ان نجاح البراسل
العسكري الروسي تتراسكي اثار كراهيه نظام
كييف وشكل خطرا عليه زخرفه اشارت ايضا الى
صحفيين الروس يتعرضون باستمرار لتهديدات
بالقتل من
اكدت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكن طالب نظيره
الفوري عن صحفي جورنال المحتز في موسكو
وفي مكالمه هاتفيه اعرب وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه عن القلق الشديد من عمليه
احتياج او احتجاز الصحفي من جانبها كشفت
وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ان مصير صحفي
الامريكي سيتحدد من قبل المحكمه كما اشارت
ايضا الى ان الوزير لابروف اخبر بلينكن
بعدم قبول تسييس القضيه واثاره الضجه من
قبل واشنطن
عام واحد على حادثه بوتشا المروع حادثه
حصدت مئات المدنيين ودمرت المدينه لكن
جهود اعاده الاعمار طوال العام نقلت
المدينه من حال الى حال
توقفت المسارات جميعها تقطعت الطرق
والانفاس ايضا هنا قبل عام حدثت الكارثه
كارثه بوتشا راح ضحيتها مئات المدنيين
المدينه المنكوبه منذ ذلك التاريخ لم تقف
صامته بل صمدت وعادت الى الحياه اهالي
المدينه لم يكن امامهم الا ترمي مما خلفته
اثار الحرب
ليل النهار اليه الاعمار طوال العام لم
تهدا اعيد الاعمار لتعود سالمه الى ساكنها
مساعدات غربيه ساهمت في نقل المدينه من
حال الى اخر
هذا الجسر بمثابه ماوى للاشخاص الفرين من
بوتشا في اتجاه كييف واوشك العمال على
الانتهاء من ترميمه بجانبه اعاده اوكرانيا
بناء 120 جسرا مدمرا واصلحت 100 كم من
الطرق وانشات 330 ممرا مؤقتا وجدت 80 محطه
سكه حديد لاسيما محطات القطار ومستودعات
القطارات
اعمال البناء حتى الان في بوتشا سددت من
الاحتياطات النقديه لاوكرانيا ومن مدفوعات
اوليه بقيمه 600 مليون دولار من بنك
الاستثمار الاوروبي
ما جرى في بوتشا تريده كييف ان يحدث في
كامل البلاد لكن التكلفه باهظه حيث يقدر
البنك الدولي تكلفه اعاده الاعمار في
اوكرانيا
ب411 مليار دولار غذاء السالم العربيه
بحث ولي العهد السعوديه الامير محمد بن
سلمان والرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
في جده العلاقات الثنائيه الوثيقه
والتاريخيه بين البلدين الى جانب افاق
التعاون وسبل تعزيزه وتطويره في مختلف
المجالات كما ناقش الامير محمد بن سلمان
مع الرئيس المصري تطورات الاوضاع
الاقليميه والدوريه
بينما ينتظر ملايين الامريكيين وطول
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامبا مهما محكمه
نيويورك طلبت رب من مواليديها التبرع
لحمله اعاده انتخابه لعام 2020
وذلك في باير نشر على موقع
قبل يومين فقط من الموعد المتوقع لتقديمه
للمحاكمه وقال ترامب النص اذا كان وضعكم
سيئا كما حال الكثير منكم فلا ترسلوا اي
شيء واذا كان وضعكم جيدا ولم يصبح ممكنا
من خلال السياسات العظيمه لاداره ارسلوا
مساهماتكم الى حملتنا علينا ان نستعد
بلادنا ونجعل امريكا عظيمه مره اخرى
[موسيقى]
رده فعل الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب كانت حديثه من حوله فكيف كان وقع
لائحه الاتهام الجنائيه على ترامب
منهم من قال بان ترامب كان منزعجا وغاضبا
ومصدوما ومن هم من قال بانه ظل هادئا جدا
ورزينا وفقا لواشنطنبوست
الرئيس الامريكي السابق بحسب مصادر مقربه
تبلغ الخبر بمكالمه هاتفيه ثم بدا بالتحرك
اتصالات بالجمهوريين في الكونغرس ووعود
بالمحاربه حتى البراءه والدفع بالمظلوميه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق سيمثل امام محكمه
منهات يوم الثلاثاء القادم قبل ان يضطر
للوقوف امام قاض للاستماع الى التهم
الجنائيه الموجهه اليه تحت حمايه امنيه
مشدده وسط توقعات من احد مستشاريه بان
يظهر الرئيس السابق دقيقا وحذرا خاصه وان
هذه تعد سابقه سياسيه وتاريخيه قد يستفيد
منها ترامب كثيرا ويستغلها في حملته
الانتخابيه للعام 2024
عندما يسلم ترامب نفسه سيتم حجزه في
الغالب مثل اي شخص اخر يواجه التهم ستؤخذ
بصماته من دون تقييد يديه ربما وسيتمتع
بحمايه الخدمه السريه ومن شبه المؤكد انه
سيطلق سراحه في اليوم نفسه
الفريق القانوني الترامب وفريق حملته
امضوا اسابيع في التحضير لصدور لائحه
الاتهام ضده بحثوا خلالها خطه الهجوم
باستخدام ورقه الدوافع السياسيه ضد مدعي
عام مقاطعه منهات ومحاميه السابق وهو احد
الشهود الرئيسيين في القضيه
ونداءات لجمع التبرعات والحلفاء
القانونيين والسياسيين والاعلاميين
مع ترقوا لما ستؤول اليه قضيه رايس
الامريكي السابق والتوتر الذي قد يتزامن
مع تقديمه للمحاكمه ما زال الغموض يلف
لائحه التهم بحق ترامب فما هي ابرز
الملاحظات على هذه التخم
قبل يومين من تقديمه للمحاكمه ما زال بعض
الغموض يلف قضيه الرئيس الامريكي دونالد
ترامب وما سيواجهه خلال المحاكمه وفيما
وصلت اليه القضيه فهناك خمس ملاحظات لما
يتهم به ترامب وما قد يواجهه اولها فان
لائحه ستبقى سريه حتى يمثل التراب امام
المحكمه ما لم يطلب المدعي العام الكشف
عنها لا تفاصيل واضحه عن طبيعه الاتهام
الذي سيواجهه لكن مصادر مطلعه رجحت ان
تتضمن تهما جنائيه التحقيق في السابق كان
يركز على دفع 130 الف دولار قبل
الانتخابات الرئاسيه باسابيع شراء الصمت
بالاموال يعتبر قضيه قانونيه لكن المخاوف
تدور حول ان تتضمن التهم تزوير سجلات
تجاريه ولاثبات تورط ترامب سيحتاج المدعون
اثبات انه كان متورطا شخصيا فيما اتهموه
به
اعترف بالدفع لدعنه ومحامه فسر الامر بانه
لحمايه زواجه لكنهم يخشون ان يسعى المدعي
العام للحصول على تهم جنائيه من خلال
تاكيد على ان المدفوعات تنتهك قوانين
الحمله الانتخابيه بطريقه ما تقول اخر
المعلومات ان رئيس السابق يريد ان يتم
تقييد يديه عند ظهور امام المحكمه معتقدا
انه سيكون استعراضا مهيبا للقوه قوه لا
يريد حتى حاكم ولايه فلوريدا التورته في
مواجهتها
[موسيقى]
وفي سباق الانتخابيه اعلن حاكم واركنسا
السابق الجمهوري اسيا اعتزامه الترشح
للرئاسه في عام
قال خلال مقابله تلفزيونيه ان عزمه الترشح
للرئاسه جاء لابعاد دونالد ترامب عن الحزب
الجمهوري مشيرا الى ان مواطني الولايات
المتحده يريدون قاده يقدمون افضل ما لديهم
لامريكا وليس الذين يستغلون اسوا غرائزهم
على حد وصفه
وكاله الانباء السوريه بانفجار عبوه
الناسفه في سياره مدنيه في منطقه المزه
بالعاصمه دمشق ونقلت الوكاله عن مصدر في
قياده شرطه العاصمه قوله ان الانفجار ادى
الى احتراق السياره دون تسجيل اصابات
في المقابل استدعى الجيش الاسرائيلي
بروحيات ومقاتله حربيه تابعه له اثر رصد
وسياره مجهوله تسللت من جهه الاراضي
السوريه الى داخل الاجواء الاسرائيليه وتم
اسقاط المسيرات في منطقه مفتوحه حيث لم
تشكل اي خطر في اي مرحله ولم يتم تفعيل
الانذار بما قدرت تحقيقات الاوليه ان
المسيره ايرانيه الصنع بحسب القناه
الثانيه عشر الاسرائيليه
على وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيليه مارلين
استعداده لتولي قياده الحرس الوطني او ان
يكون تحت قياده مفوض الشرطه تصريحات تاتي
بعد مصادقه الحكومه على انشاء حرس وطني تم
الاعلان انه سيكون موازي للجيش والشرطه
وسيتكون تشكيل الجديد من مجموعه من الفرق
الخاصه للسيطره على اماكن حساسه يصعب على
الشرطه والجيش السيطره عليها
الحرس الوطني الاسرائيلي جدل مدون في
الاوساط السياسيه
ميليشيات مسلحه ام نظام امني جديد
لم يرى النور بعد لكنه اثار حفيظه معارضين
[موسيقى]
قوه مسلحه تمنح صلاحيات امنيه
تعدادهما بين 1800 الى 2500 عنصر تكلفته
300 مليون دولار سنويا
يراسه وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
ايتامار بن غفير المستشاره القضائيه
للحكومه عارضت انشاء الحرس ووصفته بغير
القانوني
مفوض الشرطه الاسرائيلي حذر من تداعياته
الخطيره
بن غفير لم يخدم في الجيش ولا خلفيه امنيه
له
ادين بالارهاب في محكمه اسرائيليه
لانتمائه الى حزب متطرف
ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد الفاصل
اجتماع في موسكو لنواب وزراء خارجيه روسيا
وتركيا وسوريا وايران حول تطبيع العلاقات
بين انقره ودمشق
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال المبعوث الامامي الى
اليمن هانز ان الهدنه في ذكرها الاولى ما
زالت قائمه الى حد كبير ويتم تنفيذ الكثير
من بنودها حتى الان ويتم تنفيذ بنودها
وقال المبعوث الامامي انه يجب ان يكون كلا
الطرفين في اليمن على الاستعداد للجلوس
معا والتحاور بشكل جاد ومسؤول
اضافه انه لا يمكن لاي اتفاق مؤقت ان
يعالج معاناه اليمنيين وان التعافي لن
يبدا الا بالتوصل الى حل شامل للنزاع
الاتحاد الاوروبي كد على دعمه ثابت لجهود
السلام التي تقودها الامم المتحده في
اليمن داعيا الاطراف اليمنيه خاصه جماعه
الحوثي الى الانخراط مع المبعوث الاممي من
اجل التوصل الى هدنه موسعه ومطوله الاتحاد
الاوروبي اوضح ايضا في بيان نشره اليوم ان
الهدنه في اليمن ستمهد الطريق لوقف اطلاق
النار ولعمليه سلام شامله برعايه الامم
المتحده
ينعقد اليوم في العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
الاجتماع الرباعي حول مساعي تطبيع
العلاقات بين انقره ودمشق وذلك على مستوى
نواب وزراء خارجيه كل من روسيا وايران
وسوريا وتركيا وعرب المبعوث الخاص لرئيس
الروسي الى الشرق الاوسط ودول افريقيا
ميخائيل بوجدينوف عن امله ان تكون مهمه
الوساطه الروسيه تهدف الى تحقيق هدف
استراتيجي مهم للغايه وهو التطبيع
العلاقات السوريه التركيه
اعلنت صحيفه نيويورك امتناعها عن دفع اي
مستحقات ماليه ورسوم شهريه الى تويتر
مقابل علامه التوثيق والتحقق على منصتها
جاء ذلك بعدما اعلنت المنصه ان حسابات
كثيره ستفقد علامه التوثيق الخاصه بها
بدءا من الاول من ابريل وذلك ضمن خطوات
الشركه لانهاء برنامجها التوثيقي القديم
[موسيقى]
تويتر وملفه علامات التوثيق الرئيس
التنفيذي لتويتر ايلون ماسك اعلن ازاله
علامه التوثيق الزرقاء عن حساب صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز الصحيفه قررت عدم دفع
الاشتراك الشهري اللازم للحفاظ على
التوثيق ماسك هاجم الصحيفه وقال انها
تمارس الدعايه ولا يمكن قراءه عناوينها
ولا اخبارها
خدمه تويتر بلو تكلف المستخدمين الافراد
ثمانيه دولارات شهريا للحصول على علامه
التوثيق الزرقاء بينما يتعين على الشركات
دفع 1000 دولار شهريا للحصول على علامه
التوثيق الذهبي الامر ذاته ينطبق على
حسابات الاعمال التي تضم حسابات حكوميه
اضافه لخمسين دولارا اضافيا لكل حساب تابع
[موسيقى]
من احياء الحجاز والشام الى خنادق الرصاص
والموت خلال الحرب العالميه الاولى يتناول
مسلسل
سفرته الدوله العثمانيه بحق اهل شبه
الجزيره العربيه والتجنيد الالزامي للشبان
العرب دراما اجتماعيه تاريخيه لا يغيب
عنها الطابع الرومانسي ضمن القصه اخر
مشروع حضر له المخرج الراحل حاتم علي
قبيله وفاته وهو من اخراج الليث حجه
البطوله توزعت بين نجوم بين السعوديه
وسوريا ولبنان والعالم العربي المزيد مع
سهى الوعل في دراما رمضان
[موسيقى]
في اوروبا
الرجل المريض
كل الحين قاعد انتظره يموت
الكل مجتمع يبغى يسقط دوله الاسلام بابنود
[موسيقى]
هذا هو مسلسل سفر ابرليك اللي كان مفاجاه
الموسم الدرامي الرمضاني الضخمه عن كارثه
التهجير الجماعي القصري اللي طبقتها
الدوله العثمانيه عام
1915 تجاه الالاف من الرجال والنساء
والاطفال من سكان المدينه المنوره حدث
تاريخي كان من المهم جدا للدراما ان
تتناولوا يوما هذا حدث
له قيمته التاريخيه وايضا قيمته الانسانيه
ويعتبر اليوم وكانه جريمه حرب لانه تم
تهزيرها للمدينه حتى قيل في كثير من مصادر
التاريخيه انه لم يبقى الا 41 شخص من
اهالي المدينه
يقتلون المدينه المنوره تم تهجيرا بالكامل
العمل ودي عبد الرحمن المدني ورفاق دراسه
الجامعيه في اسطنبول السوري يحيى
واللبناني
لما صورنا على حدود البلقان كان كمان شيء
كتير حلو لانه عبد الرحمن مثلا كثير كان
بالنسبه له الثلج كثير كبير وكثير كان
الجو حلو هناك وما حسينا حالنا يعني انه
افترقنا هلا كتير اشتقنا للسات هون كمان
بس مره كان كمان كانت مغامره لقلنا انا
وعبد الرحمن ويحيى
الجمهور
[موسيقى]
اذا كان مكتوب على اهل ذي البلاد انهم
يحاربون
[موسيقى]
هذا تذكير بابرز العالم
بعد معارك طويله زعيم وفقنار يرفعه على
روسيا على مبنى اداره بخموت الاوكرانيه
مع اقتراب موعد مثوله امام المحكمه ترامب
يدعو انصاره الى التبرع لحملته الانتخابيه
وانفجار سياره مفخخه في دمشق والجيش
الاسرائيلي يعترض مسيره من جهه الاراضي
السوريه
نهايه هذه نشره شكرا لمتابعتكم والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]